so for the advanced class I prepared a
few games a bit more complicated than
the end games we saw earlier and this
first game is against an international
master Keaton Kara I played him in the
spice Cup open last year which is held
in st. Louis so I'm playing Wyatt I play
d4 this is what I normally play and he
played the Kings Indian defense which I
believe he usually plays or at least up
until this game he did here you play
this move c6 which is it was pretty new
for me I've never I've seen this move
before but I've never faced it in a real
game normally he plays d6 the main Kings
Indian move and then II five and just
the basic Kings Indian we've all come to
know and love of course but he played c6
and his idea here is to play d5 and to
just completely challenge and mess with
White's big center here I play Bishop e2
I figured this was a most natural move
he played d5 then I played a five and
ninety four it was pretty clear to me
that he prepared this opening before the
round because I think it was a morning
ground we already knew our pairings for
quite some time and it's always a tricky
thing when you're playing someone and
you know they've prepared for you like
some specific opening and you're not
sure what kind of traps they have in
mind and you know they've worked with a
computer and I know Keaton and I know he
prepares openings all the time so I was
a bit nervous that I'm gonna fall into
some kind of opening trap here but the
only advice I can really give you guys
just try to play what you think are the
most natural logical moves and you
should be you should turn out okay so
here after 94 I don't really want to
take this Knight
because black is gonna put a lot of
pressure on my deep on here so I can
play like Knight g5 trying to win this
efore pawn and then after c5 white
Center is kind of collapsing here I
can't really push my D pawn because II
five will hang and yeah so my Center is
falling apart and my King is still in
the center for the moment so I really
wouldn't be that happy here
instead I decided to just castle letting
him take on c3
and he took on c4
he played c5 so this was his idea here
he trades Knights and he forces my pawn
to move up to this ie v square where
it's kind of extended and after these
exchanges he gets more pressure on my
center and now this isn't really a king
xenian anymore it's kind of like a green
field defense where black has this nice
Bishop on g7 and the game is open and
they're ready to attack the center with
like moves like Knight c6 Bishop g4
maybe Queen a5 at some point and why
does to figure out a way to defend their
center here so if you guys want to
suggest a move at any point feel free
like what would you guys think about
playing here to complete your
development yeah that's a pretty logical
move I think yeah I think this moves
perfectly okay anything else
okay so what has a couple of options
here the move I played was rookie one
which i think is a pretty good move I
realize black wants to play Bishop g4
next and knight c6 and if I ever want to
play my pawn to d5 to gain more space
than my e5 pawn will need protection
especially if their Bishop is on g4
pinning my knight
so I figured rook e1 would have been a
pretty good move another good move is
just h3
just stopping the bishop from coming to
g4 and I think this is what people
mostly play in this opening today we're
still in like the opening theory stage
but I figured this one was kind of slow
and I would rather just develop my rook
and I didn't think that Bishop g4 was
such a was a huge deal
so first he took on d4 any play Bishop
g4 one thing I should mention actually
is that if Y played a move like d5 is
just trying to gain as much space as
possible this kind of strategy can
really backfire if you can't defend
these pawns adequately like for instance
black plays Bishop g4 I'll play Bishop
f4 defending the e5 pawn and 97 and
white spawns look very nice but blacks
next move is going to be Knight b6
attacking my bishop and it's not so
clear what I can do I can ever play e6
because black will take and the bishop
might have or will Hank and d6 is a move
I can also consider but it's kind of
risky the further you push your pawn the
easier it is for your opponent to attack
it and possibly win it and also after d6
but I can take and probably the pawn on
c3 is going to Hank so a position like
this at first glance looks pretty good
for white because you have these
incredibly strong pawns in the center
and all your pieces are in the center
but I think black is is really happy
here like rook e1 Knight b6 and I'm not
sure what to do with this bishop I
played but should be three black will
play c4 and win the pawn and if I defend
it with my queen then
well I can always take on f3 and double
my pawns and that's not something that I
really gonna be really happy with so I
wanted to mention that this move d5
looks good but it's not as probably not
as good as it looks
so I played Ricky one I just want to
defend my Center and keep everything
under control so he took he played
Bishop g4 I played Bishop b2 knight c6 I
pretty much more or less expected all
this when I played rook e1 so here I
could prepare them of d5 yeah go for it
if I play h3 he's he's gonna take my
knight and here you can probably take
this pawn right but even if even if you
couldn't take this pawn I can always
play a move like H Street in the future
I think it's kind of I think it's not
very flexible I did play this move but
only after a few more moves and I also
want to see if he's just gonna take on
f3 willingly because sometimes players
do that they just want to take on f3 and
for whatever reason maybe bring my queen
out so if I can induce them to play that
without this move h3 then it's like I
saved the move but h3 is definitely
moved to consider but I played d5 there
that was a good question though because
that's a very natural move to look at I
figured now d5 is okay to extend because
all my pieces are developed and my
Center is supported quite nicely and I'm
also playing d5 with a temple I'm
hitting his Knight so his Knight can't
get to like d7 & b6 real quick so he
plays Knight f5 and there should be
three bishop that phone was also good
both but I figured Bishop b3 makes sense
I don't really mind if he takes my
bishop because I'll develop my queen
with a temp
and I can bring my rook to d1 and if I
can hold on to the pawns in the center
then Y should be pretty happy here it
should be a pretty nice advantage
because the central pawns are very
strong when they're adequately defended
and this was kind of like the main theme
in the game here is that once these
pawns are defended and supported well
they become really dangerous really fast
so my opponent played rook c8 good move
and here I play h3 I'm ready to develop
my queen and connect rook so I figured
might as well play h3 here and see if
he'll take on f3 actually I think black
should play Bishop d7 here
I think taking on F there is a small
mistake and here the position is
probably better for white but it's not
it's not super clear black's pieces look
a little awkward but i think they're
they're okay
like rook c1 he'll trade and a position
like this it's better for white but
close to equal the point is that you
know black keeps this light squared
bishop and it's a very good piece it
controls a lot of squares and even
though white has more space in the
center black has this nice light square
bishop so it's not like white can really
do a whole lot immediately so I think
that's what black should have done
instead he took on f3 and you play Queen
b6 I played rook d1 just the most
natural move and here you took on b3 so
white has kind of a small decision to
make here they can either play Queen
takes b3 and allow Queen trade or they
can play a takes B 3 and keep Queens on
the board by a show of hands who would
trade Queens here
just one yeah well you're in the end
games lesson so you're you probably feel
pretty confident but your end games play
right now that's fine
how about a B who's a fan of this move
you can also stay undecided so you like
this move sure cool
yeah I played eight takes B three I
think after Queen takes B three it's
some sort of like letting block off the
hook a bit like they'll trade and
they'll play rook d8 and I think black
black is okay here I like my pawns in
the center I like that I can probably
create a passed pawn in the future but
you know Black has their own counter
play they can play rook c2 they can play
rook c5 it could be five without Queens
I can't really create any serious
threats with Queens on the board my past
D pawn is potentially more dangerous
because I can also use my Queen at some
point to make threats and an endgame
pass pawns are you know they're
blockaded and it's not so easy to win
especially if they can block hit it with
their King in the middle game blacks
never gonna block in my deep on with
their King would just be extremely
dangerous but here with the Queen on I
can create more threats so my opponent
played the most natural move here you
just played rook c2 this is actually a
pretty serious mistake but it would have
been something like Queen B for black
just needs to stay put here they just
really like they can't do a whole lot if
they get to if they try to get too much
counter play they're just gonna find
themselves in serious trouble and that's
what happened here he played rook c2
which looks so natural because there it
comes the second rank at a textmate
bishop
it puts pressure on f2 which is kind of
annoying and maybe block is ready to
double up on the C file and try to win
this b3 pawn at some point but after
Bishop a3 actually black is in huge
trouble
there's just not a good way to defend
the e7 pawn which my opponent definitely
underestimated not only is
see seven hanging but I'm also just
starting to play d6 d7 and just queen
this pawn and blacks rook on c2 is
horribly misplaced right now there are
no threats on f2 Black has no counter
play with this rook it's as if I'm
playing with an extra rook in the center
and just ready to promote these pawns I
think originally my opponent wanted to
play rook c8 in this position I mean
he's a good player you wouldn't play
rook c2 without thinking about what my
reply is or maybe he was expecting
Bishop d4 Bishop a3 I think you wanted
to see eight with the point of if I take
on e7 he plays rook c3 and he's
attacking my queen he's attacking f2 and
it looks kind of dangerous for white but
in reality if you just like stay calm
and just sort of think about the
position for a little while you'll find
that there's not that much danger here
for white so white actually has two
really good ideas here the first is to
play rook e3 so one idea for black is to
take this pawn on e5 because of the pin
on the third-ranked
why can't take the bishop and now blacks
Bishop is super active and it's ready to
come to d4 and cause a lot of grief to
my position but why does d6 and this
pawn ends up just being the deciding
factor black put both of the rooks you
know on c2 and c3 but after d6 I think
White's just gonna get a new queen and
black just doesn't have enough time to
to create enough threats but it's pretty
complicated
the other solution which might be
simpler is just Queen f4 just moving the
Queen and black doesn't have time to
take on b3 because I'm just gonna play
d6 like my bishop on e7 is perfectly
placed because it's controlling the the
queening square and I'm gonna promote my
pawn soon here is a little worried about
this move Bishop h6 and of course I
can't take this Bishop because the Queen
takes f2 check and mate on g2 but after
just a simple move Queen f6 f2 is
protected and
Black has just lost like if we trade
Queens then they don't have any serious
threats and whites deep pawn is too
strong and the game is more or less
decided and otherwise black just doesn't
have a way to keep making threats so
during the game it took me much longer
than it should have to calculate all
this but I figured my opponent is higher
rated and you know if he plays rook c8
probably it's gonna be pretty dangerous
but things often look scary and they're
often not that scary which is something
you should remember if your opponent is
trying to intimidate you that usually
means he doesn't like his position very
much well you should do is just try to
remain objective and just try to find
the best moves without thinking about
who your opponent is and whether they're
gonna make you or not
you should just try to find the best
motive look for a good defenses and hear
all this stuff looks kind of crazy Queen
f4 like Bishop h6 this would really
bother me during at the game because my
opponent has this nice deflection tactic
but once I found Queen f6 it's like okay
there's nothing here and you know I can
just play this with confidence so here
my opponent took a long time you realize
he doesn't have anything with rook c8 so
we just played rook e8 and now I play d6
so my pawn is super strong I'm
threatening to play d7 and to take his
e7 pawn with my bishop and black here is
in a huge trouble
they're basically just lost already for
instance if they take on d6 I'll take
rook takes II won and here I was there
in the game I was really worried about
rook takes f2 at first because I've
Queen takes F - he has Bishop d4 winning
the Queen right but I have this
intermediate move rook check and I I
wouldn't again yep
oh I see what you mean
eggs here check and yeah we call that a
cross pin this also looks great but yeah
I mean I saw Ricky a check so I thought
that's probably good enough there's
another funny line here but I don't
remember what it is
so forget it if black just stays passive
and plays Bishop f8 then II 6 is very
strong if they take I take with the rook
and I'm threatening D take C 7 and
there's there's no defense it's just
black is just busted here another cool
thing is if f5 just keeping the position
kind of clothes you can just play g4 and
if takes I have Queen f7 check and I
don't take the rook because I'll get
mated on f2 and g2 but I can just take
care and the game game is just over um
so my opponent here played six and this
is pretty simple now for white I was
able to just see all the way to the end
of the game which can be happy when
you're thinking you have a winning
position if you can calculate until like
the very very end of the game or until
your opponent just has to resign it's
always great you know if you can
calculate things out to the end it's a
lot better than just relying on your
intuition so d7 Fischer v7 just winning
the exchange there should by fate takes
takes and Queen f6 so can anyone see why
my opponent resigned here yes
good a good way to put it yeah there
should be seven Queen takes e7 and Y
wins so I wanted to show you guys that
game because I was really surprised
after winning it because it seemed like
white really didn't do anything special
all I did was put my pieces in the
center of the board and then once things
got a little complicated like I was able
to see all the tactics I needed to see
and was confident enough to just go for
this break okay so I'm gonna move on to
the next game
so here the opening and middle game
weren't really interesting or
instructive it was kind of just a
shuffling around a bit so I just wanted
to start from this position and here
oddly enough once we were down to like
two three minutes the game got really
exciting and here I'm playing white my
opponent I believe he's a master or
maybe high rated expert so what's going
on here black is up upon white has the
two bishops and both Kings are kind of
iffy they're not very happy here they're
both kind of exposed White's pieces are
definitely better here like the Queen on
h5 is active where the Queen on e6 is
kind of defending everything the bishop
on d4 is really nice because it controls
all the dark squares on both sides of
the board and this Bishop on d3 is also
a really important piece because it's
controlling this currency too so even
though White's King looks kind of Airy
it's practically impossible for black to
create any threats because I'm
controlling the c2 square blocks bishop
on b7 is not a very good piece it's
passive it's not um it's just defending
the pawn on d5 it's not really doing
anything else and the not only for looks
very good but this Knight actually gets
in in trouble which is why I like this
game because I I
views this poor night quite a bit in the
game and it's it's pretty interesting
even though the night us on e4 defending
everything as we'll see it ends up being
a problem piece for black so i played um
a pretty risky move here I played g4 I
figured this was a very logical move
because I want to open up this diagonal
for my bishop I want to open up the G
file and I want to try and attack blacks
King even though White's down upon here
they're really not um they're probably
not in any danger of losing if they just
stay put because blacks extra pawn is on
d5 and it's thoroughly blockaded there's
really not a whole lot black can do here
to improve their position all they can
do is also just stay put and try to try
to defend everything but of course I
wanted to win so I played g4 black took
and I played rook g1 here so here my
opponent blundered with g3 he missed
that I can just take this pawn with my
rook because the Knights pin
he should have played this funny move
Bishop c8 just defending this pawn and I
would probably play King g2 trying to
play like rook h1 and create something
against the the h6 one for instance I
want to play rook h1 and then like f5
attacking his queen and things are
pretty complicated why it's definitely
risking a lot by giving up their Jeep on
but the game continues you know we both
have two minutes like someone's gonna
win hopefully it'll be me I have the two
bishops so I feel pretty confident here
because when you and your opponent both
have low time it's well no one's better
to have the initiative because you
create threats and your opponent has to
try and defend and it's very stressful
to defend against a lot of different
threats but as it happened the practical
aspect of this sort of just paid off
immediately
you play g3 check and you just blundered
this pawn so here he played Bishop c8
he's trying to organize some kind of
defense like you maybe you can play
queen of five here he'll be pretty happy
why not a number of good ways to proceed
here I played this move rook g5 I
thought it was a cool move I'm taking
advantage of two pins aged six pawn in
the e4 Knight and I'm going after blacks
d5 pawn and maybe I want to play like
rookie five and rook e8 and checkmate
black but even stronger was actually f5
and the point of this move is to deflect
black screen so if they take I play
Queen e8 this is a whole idea to give my
queen access to the eh square and this
position is like in a lot of these
positions you'll see why the two bishops
are so strong and such a commodity is
that White's King is just perfectly safe
the bishop is controlling the F to
square this Bishop is controlling this
square black is pretty much lost here
you can take the the rook he has to go
up as Queen and well then extra queen
white white should win this position
pretty easily the Queen and Bishop I
should say I'm just going to take the
Queen side pawns and the game's over
another cool line was Queen d6 attacking
my rook on g3 which is now also pinned
but I official takes e4 takes and this
should be five just a nice deflection
tactic course if Queen takes check and
mate
so this move f5 was it was very strong
but I'd really see it I didn't actually
see this idea of Queen takes f5 and
queen bee 8 I figured with blacks Queen
on f5 they'd probably have something
against my King like Queen h5 check or
something but it doesn't
there is no Queen h5 check I just take
so I figured this was a good move a lot
of people say like when you see a good
move look for a better one but like in
time trouble if you only have a minute
left if you see a good move and you know
what's gonna move just play the good
move because you you have a minute left
don't look for anything else
the rook g5 you play Bishop b7 I played
rookie 5 Queen f7 and here what has two
options Queen takes f7 rook takes and
Bishop takes b6
with a very good endgame I went back my
pawn and with two bishops and an active
rook I I should win that in game or
Queen h4 just keeping the Queens on the
board and continuing with your attack so
I'll ask you guys again would you trade
Queens here or keep Queens on the board
you would try it okay anyone else yeah
trade does anyone want to keep the
Queen's Own cool
yeah actually I traded Queens because I
was pretty sure I could win that any
game and I did but keeping the Queens on
is probably just crushing because again
black has no threats with any of their
pieces but White has all the threats in
the world specifically I just want to
play f5 and rook g6 and then take this
h6 pawn for instance there are some cool
lines here like Knight g5 f6 check and
check
and it's gonna be mate Queen takes f7
check white wins or Rick c7 and rookie
six and Queen h5 and Queens coming in to
g6 and and the game is basically over
you know but I made a practical decision
here because I figured with low time I'd
rather just play a really good end game
rather than play a complicated position
where I might blend or something but now
looking at it like it's a pretty serious
mistake I think to trade Queens after
Queen h4 practically speaking there's no
way black can hold this position and if
I just plays f5 rookie six next it's
pretty much game over
so I traded and then I took this b6 pawn
you played a four I played Bishop c2
attacking the pawn bishop c6 of course
rook takes f4 losses because of check
and takes and miraculously my bishop on
b6 protects the f2 square so black can't
play rook F to check winning it a piece
back and this game I really like this
guy he just shows the power of the two
bishops so well the bishops just they
control everything and my opponent
actually just getting frustrated over
not being able to really do anything
here with any of us pieces while my
bishops just dominated the board and
again this 994 is in the center but it's
pin and it can't do anything so you play
Bishop c6 I played rookie 6 which is d7
and rook d6 so then I can't take and
black loses their d5 pawn you play King
g7 I took out of 6 and what move should
why play here
exactly yeah I just pin the night all
over again don't give like any freedom
and inbox system is just is just losing
here at the very least I'm gonna win
this a four pawn and then I'll have two
pawns but he played rookie seven and I
played rook d6
I pretty much calculated this out now
because it all wasn't too hard
rookies you check he takes one right
bishops I take here King d6 is the only
move to keep the knight protected and
then of course d6 so the whole game this
Knight you know has just been under
attack and now it's lost and the game
was just over okay so I'm playing white
again and my opponent here is Alex
Ostrovsky he's a feat a master he's very
good
he'll probably be an IM or GM in the
next two years or something i was
playing him and i think an open
tournament we reached this position as
you can see it's pretty complicated my
king is on f1 but blacks king is also
not that safe and he just played this
move 93 which is a really really tricky
move and you should also know that he
played this move with like a minute left
on his clock and i had about an hour
left he spent a bunch of time in the
opening and middle game so i had this
huge time advantage and then he played
this 193 and I thought I was just
winning here I thought um rook takes d3
he takes Queen e5 check if King c8 is
Bishop g4 check so I give check another
check check and I win the Queen so I
figured you know he's got a minute left
he played the first move he could see
that didn't blunder anything immediately
so I'm just winning here but things are
of course not so simple if that was it I
wouldn't be showing the
game of course if it was just one
combination the problem is after rook
takes d3 and check well I can just take
this night I take D take c2 I take Ricky
a check and like it's made it and center
of the board king of one rope do you
want
so as you can probably imagine this
rattled me quite a bit but it's a really
good practical lessons that you know you
should never assume things are simple
because they're usually not so my
opponent plays a smooth and he sets this
really it's a pretty nasty trap and of
course things are now okay for black
like black is not in any kind of trouble
at all of course if I play Bishop takes
c3 he can play rook takes d5 and you
know whites rook on each one is out of
play so I'm in I'm in pretty big trouble
here check there should be 2 and clearly
White's not happy at all blacks King is
perfectly safe I'm losing all my Queen
side pawns and yeah it's it's bad news
so I was able to find this move 93 which
is a good move because basically it
doesn't blender the game away and sort
of everything's protecting now he took
this pawn I took on b5 and he takes the
pawn on b2 with this Knight Queen takes
b2 is also possible but I'll just take
on c4 and I play Queen f4 and this
knight is pinned and I think White's
doing pretty good here my king is safe
because all my pieces are around it and
I'm throwing Rick takes h6 and I'm also
throwing Rick h5 so why it's doing
pretty good here but probably this was
the the best that black could do he
ended up taking this pawn of this Knight
which is probably a mistake and I played
Bishop f3 so this is um a pretty good
move
but it requires me to see a lot of
tactics and a lot of tactical nuances
and little details about the position
and some of my opponents resources too
so the bishop on b7 is hanging with me
like doesn't have time to take the rook
on t1 they basically have two moves here
Queen b3 and Queen a6 so Queen
eighty-six I should take the rook and I
cannot take this 9 on b2 because of c3
check at first it looks like I have
Queen e2 defending everything but here
comes a blow with d1 check and I saw
something like this during the game and
of course it freaked me out so the point
is Knight takes D 1 C 2 and if I take on
a6 Bishop recaptures gives check to my
king and black Queens and wins the game
so that is pretty terrible but what I
notice luckily is that I have Queen e5
check King a gate and then Queen takes
me to and now in the same line the big
difference is that blacks King is on a a
and after rook d1 Knight take c2 Queen
takes a6 the bishops pin he can take on
a6 and white wins so this was a really
important detail to spot Queen e5 check
because you always want to pay attention
to your opponent's resources especially
their tactical resources because if you
miss one move you can lose the game on
the spot and of course my opponent here
still has one minute left
I'm down to maybe 30 minutes you know I
want to just play fast and try to flag
him or try to make him blend or
something but he's so strong tactically
that if I miss something like rook d1
check you know I could just lose the
game immediately and that would be
pretty bad
so as it having he played Queen b3
and here I played Queen e5 check and 95
so my night gets really active and I'm
threatening 97 check which is pretty
devastating so he doesn't have time to
take the rook on d1 because it's our
favorite smothered mate but on the Queen
side which you don't see too often but
of course you also have to notice some
other things about the position and a
lot of these lines basically this rook
on h8 just ends up hanging like black
would love to just take this knight on
d5 but they can't like which it takes
I'll take with the check and you know I
can take either rook here but I mean
this is just simple and of course Ricky
eight is never possible there's a 97
check even if I didn't have this mother
made idea a 97 check always it's always
there for white so a six great move he
gets the square on a seven for his King
okay one I figured I'll put my rook here
and I'm threatening Knight c7 check and
maybe some more tricks along the a file
against this King but the position
remains pretty complicated because my
king is also not that comfortable and my
rook on h1 just isn't in the game if my
rook was on b1 for instance then
probably black had just resigned because
I would have too many threats with my
works there so you play Knight a for
blocking the a file and I play King g1
so my idea is just to play king h2 rook
b1 and that's it like I have some
possible ways to win the game here I'm
not sure if any of them work one idea is
just to play rook takes a four and if
Queen takes Knight b6 check
when's the Queen but black has Queen b1
check
and my king has to my King has to come
up or if I play Queen e1 then black and
trade Queens and my 95 is hanging so
instead of looking for something
concrete in this position I just figured
that well if my rook is on b1 obviously
Y will be winning black won't have any
defense to the threats against their
king
so King g1 must be a great move and I
mean it just it works out well for white
you play Queen B - black would love to
trade Queens here and E some of the
pressure
I gave check I gave check again and I
played can you know guess what I played
here Knight b5 on those Queens on on b7
RB - sorry
well I know you know sorry what's that
yeah perfect
skiing h2 rook comes to b1 and and and
yeah the game is just over I really like
this game because it's I don't know I
feel like I'm making all these strange
attacking moves but there's a certain
kind of logic to them and everything
kind of works out pretty rationally
he played rook to e3 queen c5 king b8
and of course I can just take this pawn
in a6 and takes and rook takes and this
should be winning of course this blacks
king is just too exposed but like I
figured I have to complete my idea would
be one I just figured like it just
doesn't matter like obviously this is
winning - so in here of course my
opponent resigned which is great if you
played on it would kind of be an
injustice of sorts I just want to finish
in this exact position
you